Você sabia que o mesmo fungo que matou
os arqueólogos que abriram a tumba do
faró Tancamon agora pode salvar vidas?
Pois é, parece história de filme, mas é
ciência pura. Pesquisadores americanos
pegaram esse fungo mortal, o aspergilos
flavos, aquele da famosa maldição do
faraó, e transformaram ele num potente
remédio contra a leucemia. Veja bem,
eles descobriram que esse fungo produz
umas moléculas chamadas asperiginas.
que conseguem bloquear a divisão das
células cancerosas. É como se travasse o
motor do câncer. O mais impressionante é
que essas moléculas são super seletivas.
Elas atacam só as células de leucemia,
não fazem nada com células normais ou
outros tipos de câncer. Um tratamento
que só ataca o vilão e deixa o resto em
paz. E olha que ironia, o mesmo fum que
ficou famoso por matar agora pode virar
a arma contra o câncer. Isso mostra como
a natureza é uma farmácia ambulante
esperando para ser descoberta.